hey guys Pete here today we're gonna
talk theories about the Arnold character
from Westworld there's a piece of
conclusive evidence as far as I'm
concerned so I'm gonna go over what we
know about him and then look at the
popular theories
I personally am leaning a certain way so
I'll explain why
definitely spoilers if you aren't caught
up with West's world through episode 7
now let's get into it
listen enigma he came out of the blue
and challenged our beliefs about what we
thought we knew about the park when he
was introduced in the 3rd episode while
we were still trying to understand how
the hosts worked and what's this deal
with milk who was who in the programming
centre else he explained to Bernard that
there there was more to the glitch that
they saw happen with some of the hosts
after the reveries update by rewatching
recordings of the event she learned that
the hosts were talking to someone and
that someone was a mysterious person
named Arnold later in the same episode
Ford explains to Bernard that he didn't
start the park himself that there were
two of them and his partner was named
Arnold
he explained they spent years refining
the host and Arnold really wasn't into
the appearance of intellect he wanted
the real thing
uh no one had imagined that
consciousness was this sort of pyramid
which Ford chose Bernard with memory
improvisation and self-interest as
levels now there was one more level he
believed but he never got there
according to for one of the big things
that blew my mind though was as he's
explaining this he talks about how the
original host had this bicameral mind
and that Bernard points out that that
theory of consciousness had been
dismissed but Ford explains that as an
explanation for consciousness not
creating it so explain that Arnold was
trying to bootstrap it in the way that
he did that was he had the host have an
inner monologue so their programming was
something that they heard rather than
just executing commands Bernard points
out that this could lead to insanity or
lunatics I think he says and you could
see that hearing voices would not be the
perfect solution for everything that a
host
the park does he also mentions that they
thought that they were hearing the voice
of God when Bernard asked Ford what
happened to Arnold he tells him that he
died in the park and it sounds like he
killed himself
there isn't much credible information
about this though because as soon as it
happened that it was it was covered up
and the corporate side of things
scrubbed Arnold from the parks history
at a key moment Ford shows Bernard a
picture of the two of them but later we
see that the person who we think is
Arnold is actually a host that's a
replicated version of Ford's father in
the sixth episode we meet a family of
hosts that Ford keeps off the radar and
he tells Bernard that they were built by
Arnold as a present for tells Teresa
that Arnold eventually went mad when
they talk at the agave plantation he
also indicates to Bernard and others
that Arnold preferred post over real
people he spent most of his time with
hosts this is unrelated I guess but it's
interesting that in present time for
does the exact same thing in the fifth
episode Ford has a conversation with the
man in black who's been looking for a
deeper meaning to the park he believes
the maze is the key to this and when
Ford questions him about whether if he
if he wants to know the moral of the
story why doesn't he just ask the man in
black says he would have to have a
shovel because he'd have to dig up the
person that died 35 years ago now he
doesn't explicitly say that was Arnold
but it fits in with everything else that
we know about him so we assume that's
what happened this is also further
backed up by Logan who says that you
know there there was two of them and one
of them died and they can't find
anything out about him from Logan we get
the idea that the park was hemorrhaging
money because of Arnold's scope and the
things he wanted to do the man in black
implies that the park was about to go
under as well and he says almost but not
because of me so basically he implies
that he saved the park in one way or the
other so we know the hosts are talking
to Arnold or at least they think they
are and then we find out from LC that
someone was using the old system to
change the hosts directives when Bernard
asked who she says it's Arnold this
could mean that he's still alive
it could also mean that his
consciousness lives on in the park
system some way I'm gonna leave that
alone for now so we can get into the
different theories about who Arnold is
but it's important to remember that she
actually disappeared
or was abducted right after she found
out this information
the first idea about Arnold is that he
actually didn't kill himself but that
Ford killed him there's a lot of
different ways where this makes sense
but basically we're led to believe that
Arnold wanted to create consciousness
and Ford was against that idea now this
could be because Ford wants to be God
and have total control we really don't
know but like I said this is what we're
led to believe that Arnold had this idea
of creating consciousness which for
whatever reason for thought was just the
worst idea in the world after seeing him
kill Teresa in the latest episode it's
definitely something that were led to
believe he might do the next idea that
gets thrown around a lot is that Arnold
was never a person at all he was
actually an assistant or host that Ford
built for some reason that he went too
far with and once he reached his
consciousness Ford was then forced to
get rid of him now this is interesting
on a couple levels but you have to
imagine in this scenario obviously we're
learning some people are that we think
her people are actually hosts so there's
a lot of validity to creating robots to
build other robots obviously they would
be very good at it and this puts forward
in a position where he has control over
the process but can automate a ton of
stuff which we see that he has a lot of
different things going on especially
with the new narrative that he wouldn't
be able to do without that kind of
assistance a twist on this could be that
he was never a host Arnold was actually
just an artificial intelligence program
and that's why it still exists in the
code personally I lean a little bit more
in those two choices if it's a binary
choice there I lean more towards him
being an actual assistant since that's
what we believe Ford was doing he was
creating this world where he could play
out these storylines but the other thing
isn't out
the out of the question obviously people
there are some people that think that
Arnold is still alive
this theory involves him dropping out
and disappearing into the park
it would give Ford what he wanted which
would be control and to bring in the
corporate people to get the park off the
ground so it's somewhat believable it's
just a little bit far out there if you
think that this has been thirty five
years and he's just randomly been hiding
out somewhere in the park now obviously
this does fit with what else he found
but I think we're gonna learn a lot more
about that so the whole Arnold was still
alive thing is really kind of not worth
digging too deeply into it's one of
those things he either is or he isn't if
he is I imagine that there's some sort
of game that goes on between Ford and
Arnold that will learn about before the
end of the season obviously you could
tack on the other theories here and say
that he's still alive because he found
this idea of how to transfer his
consciousness into the computers so his
body died but that was just a transition
to something else which is what he is
now another theory is that Arnold was
not only Ford's co-creator but it was
also his father now this all ties in to
that photograph we saw and I'm not a
huge fan of it but there is the fact
that he has this family that's modeled
after his one happy childhood memory
which if his father was his partner his
father would obviously know more about
his childhood than anyone else
Ford also tells Bernard that he had to
adjust his father's personality after
Arnold delivered him which it's a slight
nod but I don't really know how that
ties in to everything else that we're
following in this story so that's the
main reason I don't love this theory
then there's the theory that Bernard is
actually modeled after Arnold this is
the theory that I think is the most
believable and what I think stops it
from being like nearly confirmed is it
seems like such an obvious answer now
that doesn't disqualify it because
they've shown us through Bernards reveal
that they can take something that's
obvious and still make it really
enjoyable to watch one of the big clues
about this is that photograph which just
looks like it's set up wrong
I remember the first time I watched it
my initial reaction was for all that
they put into the show why would they
have such a terrible photograph there
that took me to go look at it again and
then I realized that it's really framed
where there could be a third person
and if there was a third person and it
happened to be Arnold who looks like
Bernard he wouldn't be able to see it
now that in itself is not an explanation
of why we got to where we're at now but
I do think it makes a lot more sense and
it still works with the idea that
Arnold's actual consciousness is in the
system somewhere the photograph is a
good piece of evidence but I think what
is most compelling about this to me is
that when I've been going back and read
watching the episodes you realize that
when Dolores is hearing voices like when
she goes from her sleep out to her yard
and eventually finds the gun it sounds
like Bernard I mean it is the actor
Jeffrey writes voice that she hears you
may not have made the connection when
you watch those episodes I know I didn't
because I wasn't fully invested in the
alternate timeframes that everything was
happening in if that's the case the old
Dolores who's on an adventure with
William has definitely heard the voice
of Bernard which we could say means he's
Arnold it's definitely not perfect but
it's the best that there is and it's
further backed up by those secret
meetings they have we've seen that that
room that we don't see anywhere else is
under Ford's cottage where he keeps his
unregistered family it may not be the
exact same room but it's very similar so
at the very least where those things are
happening looks like it's in the past
another thing that stands out about
these scenes is that she is fully
clothed and when we see them in the main
programming center the hosts are always
naked it's circumstantial as well but
that those those whole scenes that they
have together are completely unlike any
other scene that we see where someone
who works for the company is
interviewing a host now there's a lot of
creative editing in this show which
makes everything very
fusing I think it's set up that way
because they know people are going to
wonder about this or that so this
obviously takes a bit of disbelief about
how the scenes are arranged in present
time in retrospect after finding out
Bernard is in fact a host in present
time it kind of makes the whole
conversation they have about her
becoming conscious a little strange if
Ford has total control over Bernard why
would he have that be something that
could possibly happen I mean in the
present day he can literally put Bernard
into analysis just like they do with
Dolores those are the most common
theories and there's a lot more evidence
that we can talk about in the comet for
example several people brought up the
idea that was on reddit a while ago that
that the name bernard Lowe is an anagram
of Arnold Webber so yeah there's that
there's just a ton to speculate and just
massive room for random speculation so
if I don't stop here then we'll end up
in a rabbit hole in the video lasts
forever there is a part of me that
questions what we know about Ford and I
think the disagreement between him and
Arnold is the most important part of
figuring this out unfortunately we're
not really gonna get that though or get
there because Ford is in a position
where he's the only one who could give
up the true story of course maven
Dolores could figure it out but they're
ultimately under his control so what are
the chances one point that we should
keep in mind is that for a guy who knows
everything about the park the show has
led us to believe that he doesn't fully
understand the maze this would lead to a
whole different video if like if I
really get into the maze stuff but we
had that scene where he is in his office
and he pulls out that old sketchbook
whether that was misdirection or not he
looked like he was trying to figure
things out like he looked like he was
bewildered most of the evidence here
doesn't make any sense if there aren't
two distinct stories happening at
different times for example a Bernard is
a host version of Arnold we would need
those conversations he has about the
maze to be in the past this has to be
Arnold or at the very least an older
version of Bernard talking to Loras or
else the whole thing falls apart there
are some things that we know
at this point we know that hosts can be
replications of real people since we've
seen Ford's unregistered families since
they are the old mechanical hosts we
know that this was possible when Arnold
was supposed to be alive we know that
hosts approaching sentience can deceive
the text and that Dolores is even able
to lie directly to four we know that
Bernard is a host that were led to
believe is completely under the control
of four even to the point of killing
interestingly we seen that the young
version of Ford kills his dog and when
ass says that he did it because Arnold
told him to I think the extremity of
killing a person goes beyond normal
deception that Dolores and Maeve exhibit
but you can't say that for sure until we
know lastly we know that adding the
reveries in the code had some sort of
cascading effect on the hosts
functioning they started hearing
Arnold's voice at that time and that was
followed by mysterious changes in the
code coming from the transmitter in the
theater that Elsie found there is one
more theory that's been picking up steam
and I didn't mention it with the others
because it frankly isn't very popular
the theory supposes that Ford is a host
and that Arnold was the maker sort of
the original Ford the guy in charge of
the park now is the first host to ever
become sentient and he turned on Arnold
after that happened I don't think there
is much of any strong evidence for this
other than Ford's incredible control
over things he constantly surprises us
to how he has his power consolidated in
such a way that gives him a great
advantage of every situation he's been
up against he seems almost superhuman
which means in a show about robots you
have to wonder if he is one let me know
what you guys think about this one
though it's easy to jump on board when
you hear it but what is the actual
evidence that you're using to back it up
it would be a twist though I can give
you that I think that's about it without
going really deep into a rabbit hole let
me know what you guys think though in
the comments do you think Arnold is
still alive
was he even a real person was he Ford's
father or is it just a ghost in the
machine who lives through his code
what about burne Arnold do you think
Ford created Bernard and Arnold's image
and if so what does that mean
where this thing is headed please like
the video if you enjoyed the discussion
and subscribe to my channel so you'll
know when new videos come out thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon